alright tinsy MCO which you're all very
from San Diego California San Diego and
tell me what your family had both your
pants Corona
no actually I didn't it was kind of a
back and forth thing I spent more time
with my father than I did with my mom
you know yeah I moved out real early
about 17 years old you know I mean I've
been on my own since Dean and never
really turned back so you know so when
you left when you left your dad's house
she went where I got my own place
well actually I had a friend who had a
chick and he I don't know why he agreed
to it but long story short I moved in
with her we was that was hit her a part
of the spine this was my party spot and
I had me some cheeks and I got half the
spine being he and the more baked and I
took over the whole spot you know wasn't
made a nun being a knight but it was it
was my it was my own you know and I was
I was really young and happy to have it
you know and how did you get into being
a pimp what age did that happen
I was playing around at 16 I started
really getting into it at 17 but I like
to say that uh I was straight legs no
chased by the age about 1920 man you
know cuz a lot of time we do a lot of
mixing and doing a thing that the game
really wouldn't will frown upon at a
younger age if I didn't really have
nobody to tell me or taking by the hand
and say oh man II was opposed to do it's
not with what you're not supposed to do
I mean I did so so many things now that
I look back on fighting hilarious you
know one thing I used to do I had a 84
Cadillac from old bucket I think I
might've paid five or six hundred
dollars for I don't remember but um I
had about I want exaggerate but I know I
had enough chicks to where I had a car
low in the Cadillac I start to go back
to my house and go get another one or
two of them and I'm pulling up on the on
the stroll with a old dirty bastard
bumping hey dirty baby
and it's all types of real pees out
there man and I got the windows down the
chicks all out the car and dancing and
I'm thinking that these cats and he's
real these real players and pimps out
there is hating on me
that's my mind so they hating on me Mary
they mad cuz they see all this here and
they just don't want to see me shine but
reality was I was really making it hot
you know I'm saying I'm really drawn to
much attention and you know it was it
was a bunch of different things along
those lines you know I'm sorry to know
what tell the chick the charge my chicks
out there charging twentieth and twenty
five hours I'm going home with faux
chicks four or five chicken with a
matter of maybe four or five hundred I
was at the end of the night and I'm and
I'm thinking they mad at me because I'm
my chicks in out of cars but not that
mad because they chicks is charged in my
name so of course they don't get no
money you know I'm saying so that's
basically beginning of my my game you
know so you didn't have any role models
or anyone to guide you not not as far as
this goes no you know I didn't I think
the first role model I had they could
really tell me any news I could use was
Bishop Don Juan and I met him I believe
in a probably oh four so I was about 24
and I was younger than that cuz I don't
we'd be a real flavanol that by then so
I was like 22 when I met I met Bishop
Don Juan you're very from the best and
he didn't only just tell me what to do
you know I'm saying that the most value
information was was what not to do what
mistakes not to me and that was the the
most valuable you know because you know
you could listen to a person tell you
what to do and that's only giving you
the game that date indeed you did be
copying and repeating but the most
valuable game I would learn was game
when a person who took the time and tell
me hey man don't do this man avoid that
speed bump watch out for that pop that
pothole you know and and that's what
gave me such a longevity in the game I
mean you know I did that from from that
a dog at the 33 and I didn't ever I
never did nothing else in between them
times but you know
wasn't no wasn't no game playing whether
Noah selling drill the southern dope it
wasn't nothing like that every doll I
had smelled like [ __ ] up and from from
the time of nineteen all the way up to
thirty like I said before that eighteen
seventeen I was mixing and doing other
stuff too so how many girls did you have
in your stable did I then yeah oh man I
didn't I know I came to the ball with
probably four or five at some time and I
leave the other ones at home I mean I
don't I don't I don't had quite a few I
don't have quite a few you know and
these things I could say because it's
it's all document I don't have to a guy
and got a high definitely know and yes
so you did some prison time recently yes
yes yeah it's very much so federal
prison seven years for what it was
actually a RICO charge and then I it's
really because I went to trial and I
went to trial I fought the federal
government and I'm they tried to give me
twenty three years and I just went to
trial on it just--there's and the inside
of the case there's all types of things
you got young cast pimping on minors and
so forth and so on and when you're
dealing with a RICO case everybody gets
charged with the same crimes and that
was part of my issue with it not even
one that I didn't want to be put into
that same bag with a what a bunch of
guys that made the wrong decisions and
rather than take this plea deal what I
would have went straight home
I would rather fight it you know you
know see what comes to me and take take
my chances and seven years were for
temping and Patrick Rico Rico
racketeering enterprise death death the
main char I said yeah so when you had
things going smoothly before the
government got involved the arrangement
with the girls is that you keep how much
of their money how much can I get
and the fender girls are the races you
name it I prefer not to have black
chicks you know I'm saying
I started off that way so I got a good
dose of exactly the strain on the game
that they can they can give you if they
allow you to but being a black man
myself going to school with them and
being around my neighborhood you be real
familiar with I mean those are most
likely gonna be your first your first
chicks you know I'm saying and uh so
that's where it started off with but
when I got my first piece of snowman I
was turned out I was kind of the money
the money difference was just too much
of a comparison even to even think about
and I'm so I kind of focused my way
there you know but uh what's the problem
with black girls well headstrong if you
can say that you can say that word I'm
gonna say this man and they money don't
match their problems you know I'm saying
the purse don't match their problems and
that beauty probably you know me if I
could if I can give me all the problems
you won't if I'm making a million
dollars that I don't mind but I'm not
gonna deal with so many problems $400
you know I mean I'm not gonna do it you
know and then it was just too much for
me you know and then to be honest it
evolved more into a I'm really deep into
my into my culture as well and I really
didn't want to feel like I was bringing
more on to my people within a hour you
can went through you know and this is
just an awakening that I had at some
point you know in the game as well you
know and that's that's a whole nother
subject that uh you know might want to
go into some other time but it all just
made more sense to me because that's
what liking me you know I mean I like I
like would like me to you know and for
the most part you know white sheiks kind
of big you know I mean and uh kind of
dig down so as a pimp you provide
security your money manager tell me tell
me what what you what you're doing and
it'd be easy to tell you what I don't do
okay
you know I'm saying and only thing I
can't provide for them
it's a rest hazing other than that I
mean you name it I mean that's my job
you know I mean because they give me a
or they give me a hundred percent you
know why why when the chicks say well
can I give you past my money so I'm
again you have my Pippin man you know
and when you get down to thinking about
it not with that you know I'm saying
they're going they're going 100 percent
you're not why need 100 percent so that
and that entails when they need comfort
when they need somebody to talk to when
they need a tampon sometimes they might
you know I mean you gonna have to go do
it you know I mean if if that's really
your chick like that I mean I first year
growing I might have had a problem with
it in my mindset but I got past that
real quick you know I mean what you need
I'll go get it you know I mean if you
busy or something going on so there's
nothing I won't do you notice it's
almost the whole bonnie-and-clyde
syndrome thing you know I'm saying
whereas you know it's me and you against
the world and you know it's whatever and
you also got to realize these cats each
day these youngsters man it ain't it
ain't really so much how it was back
then because back then yo chick risked
her life for you every night every night
you know I'm saying it wasn't no
Internet where the he can be tracked in
the phone knows we found cameras at the
hotel might see the guy come in man yo
chick getting in and out of car that
random spots going to random places and
if you I started when it wasn't really
everybody having no cell phone so a
chick gonna have to go to a pay phone
and call you you might not even have no
phone yourself you wanted to just ride
up and down the stroll until you see her
back down you know I'm saying so during
those times yes a chick gonna pay for
security and all that now Dave man a
chick is paying you because she wants
somebody to to share her lifestyle with
pretty much you know so it's almost like
a romantic relationship right I mean
that's what I see it evolving to a lot
man it's really hard to find people to
find players and parents men
really really sticking to it based on
the principles of the game you know I
mean they they plan on them they plan on
these chicks mine says and playing
boyfriend and stuff and that's why you
see when these Internet's like shut down
he left a lot of prostitutes with
nothing to do he'll know where to go
what to do and he do they sitting there
stumbling twitting they thong and they
don't know what to do it was easy to
just go post the chick and wait for the
phone to ring but you know they can't
happen no more now you got to think
outside the box they got to figure out
man okay she here she ready to get it
but where i'ma do with where I'm a
sinner too you know I mean it now it's
all the old veterans and all the guys
that started from way back seat is easy
for them because they didn't have all
this even if they was using the computer
these days now is just something I was
taking advantage of but they Nasser was
said to wear you know I could take this
chick and put her in front of a foreign
video store she gonna give money there
or I could take it to this hotel because
it's gonna be a big convention this this
week in town and she could walk around
downtown and maybe I'm saying there and
they're gonna think outside the box
because of what's going on in the area
but see they not doing that now all they
knew before was posted chick wait for
the phone to ring you know I mean then
worse than that half the chick ain't
gonna do nothing if the phone ain't
ringing they're not gonna go there
that's too much work for them it was
easy to sit at the room and watch TV and
play on the Internet until a day came
but you think using a brain to figure it
out you then thinking not ain't not with
that man ain't not up with that do you
have sex with the girls I have I have
I'm not all of them you know I mean
because with me it was a matter of I
have to feel a certain way long when I
said the feeling when I had to feel that
she's really for me cuz in me I get back
being you'll get a lot of chicken you'll
know you would know you'll feel like I
might have I might get a week or two run
out of this one I might get a month run
out of this one you know I mean she she
she she didn't came from five or six
other cats so I know I might get two or
three mom not nailing her I ain't got
none [ __ ] but if I know that chica is
really really for me and I could see her
heart did
she wants to do is make me happy but I
turned me on
I can't lie to you you know I mean it's
a real turn-on to me to know that you
know I mean it there she there for me
you know I come from a background I
ain't got much family I don't have a lot
of people that I could have turned to
and stuff like they're growing up so
with that being said my females that
came off and my female became you know
the first thing I knew about what love
even resembles you know I mean was dim
so that's when I I would feel a sexual
attachment to them but without the
dedication I don't I don't feel it and
being you know the type of pimp that I
have been you'll give females they just
want to come with you because of your
name they want to be seen with you they
want to be known because they wish you
were whatever and after the after the
glitter and the grime wears off and they
realize oh I'm still doing I'm still
working I'm working even harder you know
I'm saying I got it you know I mean they
don't be worth the the status is ain't
worth to work to them so at em type of
chicks know I'm not going to let them
get a piece of me and run off but as far
as just having sex when there have been
quite a few that I've been you know that
I felt that way towards you know I mean
and it's not something that you know you
do everything I do every night or every
day but if I feel that way toward the
chick here I might that's gonna be when
I know I can
I might have five of them and and out of
that five two or three of I might
actually be really like that but the
other two you know I already know that
is they just here for the meantime
they're gonna go to another pimp another
pimp and you always got to remember
whatever happened they're gonna run that
to them you know I'm saying me I don't
want to hear about other pimp you know
I'm saying
imma be able to figure out about him
about what you do but with the chick the
how she interacts how she don't need to
even hear about him
but the other dude a lot of times they
don't want to hear about me what was he
like
what was he doing so my reputation gonna
spread through her and I got to be I had
to be thoughtful of that when uh when I
deal with a chick because she's gonna go
somewhere else I got to make sure that
whatever I do with her I'm not gonna be
ashamed of her telling you know I'm
saying or speaking on
the reputation or the stereotype that
timpz had or have is that they
intimidate or they force the girls into
doing things but it's actually much more
well I mean you got some that's the
gorilla pimp
they don't mentality you know I mean but
uh my prosecutor on my case she even
spoke on and said no he's a either
finesse pimp
you know I mean because of course the
jury wants to understand you know they
don't understand how there's no victim
saying oh pmc did this to me or did that
to me so she had to explain to them you
know he doesn't force them to do
anything
you know he is my thing is this but if a
chick don't want to be with me to do
what i or do i need her to do then i
don't want her around because i believe
inside of me that when I talk to and I
can I give her this gang that's what
she's going when they're gonna be no way
around it you know I mean she's gonna
want to do that and it's not it ain't
gonna last long no way
now I get runs when I'm with a run is
basically when I get a chick I don't
have a most of the time for know a
couple months most of the chicks I've
had in my life I've had for years and
years and years see them saying so when
you're dealing in that it's just a whole
different ballgame you know and when you
guerrilla pimping on the chick a lot of
times they gonna last long because at
some point it's not her family her mama
or whatever somebody can get in her ear
and you know another pimp gonna let her
know and he ain't gonna do that or
whatever and she might just you know run
off as far as chastising them I know
dude that you know physically chastise
the chick and they not consider gorilla
pimp they just discipline her see what
I'm saying so it's a difference now if
you get dude there's pulling up on the
whole strolling and throwing the chick
in the car and telling the chick here
she gotta work that's the gorilla pimp
mentality and to me mash is too much
work if I could imagine I could I could
never dresses it sound like too much
work what's the personality trait that
helps you to the most to succeed at this
honesty I mean as far as as far as I go
I mean there's no honesty factor whether
it's at
good or not we want to win a woman here
that she's gonna believe it's more
honesty to come and they feel
comfortable with honesty you know I mean
a a chick might come to me and tell me
well I want to work I want to do this
for you but uh I'm doing this because I
want to be your girl into nyla and I
tell it like nah they ain't gonna be
that this is how it's gonna work
you know I'm saying she might not agree
with that you know I'm saying but I'm
gonna give her some some some incentives
that to take the place of that and we
want to work out an agreement because
I'm not fitting to sit here and tell you
that I'm gonna do it be this guy or be
that guy for if I'm not because you're
gonna still expect that you know like I
said you put your life on the line for
me every day so she's gonna have those
expectations in the end so I think that
the honesty that I give them whether it
be the hard truth or not it's really
what uh what they appreciate I got
chicks that I dealt with like I say from
from knows you when I was 18 19 17
they called me through my hole [ __ ]
send me pictures through my whole big
you know I mean and all they tell me is
all you dudes later is you know I've
never met anybody like you and everybody
I've met since you was just you know and
I think it's because the honesty that I
gave them and the you know I just always
was clear with him from the gate I'm not
good at remembering a lot you know and I
tell my son about you know all these
rappers talking about boss this and boss
dead and I said man a boss ain't got a
lot of nobody when you lie to somebody
as a boss that means they are boss now
you are boss and you lying to somebody
you are not that person becomes your
boss cuz I never I don't see no reason
why boss have to lie to a subordinate
and I'll take that mentality with me so
I even called myself attempting a lot to
a chick I just feel like I didn't made
her my boss and I can't I don't out that
won't work well with me you know I'd
rather tell the truth and and to her and
walk away and see what happens and I'm
be honest which man eight times out of
ten they're gonna appreciate it and
they're gonna come around do you ever
have girls that are doing more than just
having sex for money they're kind of
figuring out who's got money and trying
to figure out ways to get it I mean at
first I wasn't with that you know but
you start hitting each other Stacy's
Miami
Memphis Tennessee and Chicago man you
learn about these about the chicks they
know how to how to slip a Rolex and
crack them a safe and you know I
remember you know being with a bunch of
peas on the whole stroll or something
somewhere in Miami or something man
what'd you get tonight me I'm popping my
yeah man I got about two thousand
dollars man yeah that chick really been
around here getting it man and you know
I'm saying I'm thinking I'm popping you
tell me yeah yeah well my chick made
about 35,000 a night you know I'm saying
I'm like you know I mean I didn't really
get it today broke it down to me you
know I'm saying they can go get a piece
of jury or something in go get the money
forward and that chick ain't even
looking she ain't even looking to to
have sex for real I mean if it like that
and that's all that's going on is what
she will do but that's not her first
initiative with them doing them chick is
trying to make a hundred thousand that
week you know I mean and um I picked up
on it but I never really school chicks
on that the chick had that mindset and
that skill set okay well okay you know
our nursery but at the same time you
also don't want to put a chicken neck
situation that ain't built like that and
then she get in trouble of some and then
she get caught now she feel like you to
read it and now she want to bring you in
on you know I'm saying but if that's the
chick mentality that's her thought
process but I mean she gonna do it
either way or you know all you can do is
make sure she do it right so yeah you
definitely uh I definitely evolved into
some of that as well
but I wasn't fortunate enough to have as
many as my chicks like that's my friend
hat because like I said a lot of time
then was the black chicks there was a
you know fast like that so you know me
having white girls and different races a
lot of times they'd be a little more
apprehensive let's say about those type
situations and I was okay with that you
know you have how many kids I have two
boys I don't have any kids to grow me to
girl yes how would you feel about one of
them following debts footsteps it's
funny because uh me and my son had a
conversation often as a child
to hide it from you know I tried to tell
him that I was in the music industry and
all the women he would see around me was
girls from the videos you know I came
with all type of drag but the thing
about it is these are the females
they're raising you know I spent a lot
of time doing that and I got
incarcerated when they were around the
ages of 13 and 12 and 13 so you know the
Internet's dear they can they can look
and they can they can they can figure
out you know seeing what the old man is
up to and I believe they might have
known a little bit prior to that but I
was still tonight you know I mean and
they would just come out and say well
this is what you're doing that or but
they would ask you know like what does
she do you know that now the internet'
ages I didn't go Instagram and see one
of the chicks that I got with at is half
out you know I'm saying or some sort of
it was getting kind of harder to even
keep up that facade so long story short
I did a lot of trying to hide it and now
they're of age I really I prefer that
they that they find something that they
really truly love because the way I
pimped it was it was way harder you know
I'm saying well way I did it you know a
lot of times where I might meet a chick
at a club you know I mean in a model
chick I lived on South Beach for a while
and I meet model chicks in and I'm
talking about really beautiful women
from other countries and we might be
back at the house I might be they had
all kind of drinks I'm talking about
three or four they get to kissing and
playing on each other but I know I can't
have sex one because if I do and my mind
brings my value down and they bringing
my value down it's gonna make it hard
for me to knock chicks and get more
females because I don't have the I was
never the outgoing pimp they walk up to
every female he saw man what's going on
with your baby I never did that I built
up my reputation in the hopes that a
female will find me
you see what I'm saying and the only way
you're gonna do that is by showing a
sense of exclusivity is what I like to
call it you know the more exclusive I am
the more they want me you know and then
when chicks is going back telling them
grow up spend the whole night at his
house and I step in and bail he wouldn't
touch me you know I mean I
the girl she telling gonna be like for
real and it's gonna it's gonna make them
wonder it's gonna open up their
curiosity so if the girl I did that we
don't want to pay me or give me nothing
the chicks keep telling my glove well
that's the type of guy I won't you know
I'm saying because especially a
prostitute because a prostitute don't
want to be out working and getting your
money just to find out you over here
spend the spending all day with this
free girl I having sex with her and
spending money on her that's the best
that's a turn-off to her when she know
her do didn't have sex with her to begin
with when he first met her - he got paid
then she knows her mom she can go to
work with a clear head knowing that's
not what he's doing now you know I mean
her focus is my dude is a businessman
whatever he's doing is for us anything
many movie maker is gonna benefit us as
a whole there's the way I the way I grew
up in pain I didn't get do a lot of
things that I wanted to do you know I
had to deprive myself of quite a few
things I mean I didn't I didn't engage
in my first menage a twice I was 30
years old you know I'm saying I was
ducking that I was I was really ducking
that you know I mean I I wasn't having
sex unless a female paid me you know I'm
saying up front you know I mean wasn't
no you know just meet old Sally down
here and I'm giving it to it in the
night hoping that she decides to give me
money later I wasn't doing under that
and but that's something that of course
every man wants to do and I want that
for my kids you know I want my kids to
be able to say I just met this chick I
think she's attractive and you know I
like her you know I'm saying I wanna you
know go spend now I want them to think
that way and go do it why because they
got whatever business they got going on
or whatever life started they living is
producing they finances and they not
having to do they're not having to judge
they they fun time entertainment time
based on how they make their money you
know but at the end of the day at that
anything that they decide to do I'm
gonna do my best support them and be
there for them because I know I know how
it's like to not have to not have that
you know I mean but my thing is to try
to steer him into a direction it's gonna
be something that they really feel and
they enjoy and if they
and it's in their heart you know I mean
you know to do because this right here
this ain't this ain't something that's
hereditary this is something that that's
instilled individual by individual it
don't matter if you your dad was a pimp
is something the matter of if you got it
in your heart it's gonna be in you
regardless is we was raised by who you
grew up and around its gonna being
something that was in you from birth and
my mind said I believe that where drugs
every part of your your seeing as far as
me you or the girls I don't I don't do
drugs I like I used to smoke weed a lot
of weed at one point in my life I sip
promethazine and codeine you know I was
real I was real tight at one point with
the rapper a pen see if black people
know about that whole whole situation
you know with his past and he kind of
changed my whole thinking around it was
something that he was really dedicated
to you know both of us stopped doing so
you know after that I kind of left that
alone but other than that I just smoked
weed and drink the champagne you know I
will be hard for me to do drugs when I
don't allow my cheeks to you know
they're gonna be curious and they don't
want to know they they might not do
around me but they'll go out somewhere
and experiment if if they saw what I did
you know so your girls are not into it
no I don't even really I would prefer
not even smoke cigarettes you know I'm
saying so drugs a no-no you know cuz who
gonna get the money first if she got a
habit he's gonna go to the dope man I
got a way for him to get you this before
I get mine there's no I'm saying I'm
with that you know I'm gonna say I've
never had a female that did but I didn't
know about it you know I went through a
phase in my life
well I didn't even know what crystal
meth was you know and that's a drug
where female that still be beautiful I'm
talking about real beautiful and she's
gonna go be able to work for 14 hours 20
hours straight so you think you just got
a cold chick man this she she did so
much about my money all she care about
is getting my money but really she is
that
hyped up on the stuff to where it she
don't even realize it
I'm a date at time of night all she know
is she want to keep going and keep
active and she just keep getting money
and I didn't I didn't know I didn't know
the difference I didn't know what it was
I'm looking for chicks on crack you know
those types of drugs so I didn't know
about that so when I was find out but
when I was learning about it now to do
my best to try to get him some help as a
matter of fact there's a chick out there
when she was on this show it's on
Netflix it's called addicting she's the
chick that I had at one point and I had
to sit down and talk to her when my
other chick told me what she does and I
let her know I'm like look man you know
you know you shoot you know go get
yourself straight and you can do
everything right you can always come
back you know I mean I sent her home and
go you know on the plane and go get
right and she didn't immediately go do
it but one of my partners called me one
day and said hey man you check on this
show they look at all next place and
there she was you know I mean and she
was blowing big clouds of smoke of
crystal smoke at one scene and anybody
end of the show she was in rehab and you
know at the end I guess it was a months
later and she was doing good you know
she never did come back but the case in
fact is is that you know she went and
got herself right and I've never been
the type to want to just have a chick on
drugs and the money wasn't that serious
to me because I've always been confident
oh I'll go get another chick you know I
mean I my game well the way I'll put it
down I can do better and she can do
better so there's no point of us doing
that so the laws have changed quite a
bit over the years since you started
right you know when I got when I got
arrested see I didn't I played the game
to where I could never be arrested but
for pimping you know saying that's the
way the law is set up that's not really
no big charge man you might do two or
three years what had long as you got a
woman of age and all you're doing is
pimping you ain't forcing her you ain't
you know whooping at her death
you ain't we looking at no time and
that's why mental now that my mind said
so I was ready for that if that ever
came but it was no need for that to ever
happen so I thought it was mean I
thought it wouldn't be no problem
well now they got this there's this law
called the RICO you know and they can
get you for just being
associated with a group of guys that
maybe pimps a group of guys that maybe
drug dealers a group of guys that maybe
gang members and and being with that
group is all it takes to catch this
charge you see and uh that's something
that a lot of a lot of these cats don't
know man and uh they don't they don't
really exploit that as much as they
should so they'll see me getting
arrested and say oh man he just he did
that wrong he did this wrong
no you ain't got to do nothing wrong all
you got to do is be with around some
other pimps you don't know what they do
when they go home or what they're doing
with this chick of that chick but you
hanging out with you thinking in your
mind well I don't do what he do I ain't
got going on what he got going on but
that doesn't matter it in all that
matters is you're associated you know
and uh that's gonna be the downfall
that's what's going that's what's gonna
get you you know so if you're not ready
for that you're not prepared for that
man you know this there's something that
you don't even need to be involved in
you need to find you a job at a lawyer's
office at McDonald's you know I'm saying
so that's one of the main things that I
missions that I'm making my life right
now is to kind of make being John castor
where what they get me into cuz you're
not just gonna get on get into this
thinking of your mom I'm just gonna make
some money out of some chicks I'm gonna
get rich nut is there's pitfalls that
can come your way and I'm a perfect
example of that you know I mean this
could happen to me could happen to
anybody because in my mind I don't I
don't break no a lot on did I don't deal
with no minors I don't know
I ain't beating up on she's not in
fourth no chicks that do nothing
I said back in and look at all the other
casts I was doing that and be the first
one to sell you he he messing up he's
gonna be in trouble it's gonna happen to
him he gonna be but it happened to me
you know I mean they're gonna constantly
make these laws they called it human
trafficking now that term used to mean
coming from one country and you bring
them out just cuz you don't mean that no
more it mean coming from the club to the
to the computer you know I'm saying that
you just an human traffic search you
ain't even took our block you know I'm
saying so that's just really one of the
main thing that I really got to focus on
you know now
I focused my cellphone trying to find
ways to evolve you know and take what
I've been and how I've been the person I
have been to evolve to where you know
they don't have no reason to come mess
with me when they look at me they may
say yeah well this is what he was doing
is what he had going on but when they go
down the whole list of things they don't
have no reason to come lock me up no
more and I'm gonna make sure that
everybody else that's coming up in this
game like I did man avoid that this is
the potholes and and and dips in the
road and bumps and Road I was talking
about earlier this is my way to give
back you know like I said Bishop Don
Juan gave me the potholes and pitfalls
to avoid but during his time it was an
issue there is time you know they just
came from the Mafia area when they was
getting the RICO charges that's what it
is it's a mafia charge so basically
that's what was going on man it was no
need to tell young pimps about that
because it wasn't going on but now it's
my generation
and this is the this is the game that I
need to get in you know and that's
really why I like to still be out and
talking to these young cats man I got to
let them know man that uh you know it
ain't it ain't all peaches man you got
to be able to move smooth and you got to
move correct and you got to really think
about your game and you got to make sure
it's what you really want to do and the
risk that you want to take because it
this is what could happen I almost did
seven years behind this man and I missed
a lot of time on my kids my kids grew up
on me you know my mom she she a time as
my best friend in the world and I miss
timing my partner's you know I'm saying
my mother my best friend you know my
family Don Juan little mac little auntie
and all them man and all my people in
Chicago and you know from state to state
music this is my family ain't just my
pimp partners that just do that I don't
you know these are my family and friends
that I put my life on the line for and
you miss you you're gonna miss out on
time with them so you got to make sure
that you ready for that and that you
prepare to do that you know I mean last
anyone do is get there and they give you
these paperwork and tell you hey man you
want to go tell on so-and-so because
whatever application you didn't build
all them years it's over with it's over
with
which of the girls that you've had in
working for you it's been your favorite
oh man see you gonna give me in trouble
with that one I guess yeah I'm not gonna
say no names but uh had a real real good
chick man and uh this was years and
years back young lady young lady had a
twin sister and she was so down she
brought a twin sister around and uh
having twin sisters at a time when host
ro was poppin man you can't imagine how
amazing that was for my reputation you
know I mean to have twins walking twin
models walking up and down the whole
stroll another and really down for it
and really really about getting getting
my check man and that was you know and
she knows who she is but she doesn't
know how I feel about her you know she
knows that I was real fond of her and so
yeah III had her and I've had a fight
quite a few others that to this day I'm
still in contact with I'm actually I'm
in contact or maybe 90 or 85% of them
even just as friends you know I mean we
just we know we just still friend a lot
of them is older now they might be in
the church you know might have here they
had regular jobs families husbands and
all types of stuff but you know they're
gonna always check on me and make sure
I'm all right and if they anything for
me they can always get it from so you
know like I said being honest being an
honest pimp and uh you know always
sticking up to Maya in the bargain and
doing it I'm posed to do makes it to
where it's kind of hard to choose who my
favorite would have been because I've
had so many good ones like I said I
could run five years seven years eight
years so it's kind of a toss-up it's
about a tie between about three or four
of them just honesty you know it is it
yeah that's that's the basic point of it
man you know but I had to get the first
one heard because she really put herself
out there for me I mean one time I was
on the stroll and I was with a good pen
friend of mine Manning and some ain't
tried to rob me and try to jump out on
me and beat me with bats and all type of
stuff man and she came from from where
she was working that down the street and
she fought him off when when nobody else
was able to do anything you know and
this is the same chick I'm talking about
so we didn't just go for her getting
money they weren't getting money to her
putting her to hurt her life was
unimportant in her own mind compared to
mine and and and the stories could just
going on and on with her and several
other chicks man some of these chick
dude and made and fainted sort of bring
a tear to go off you just really was
there to see it really like you know I
mean who was a movie you know you've
been posting a movie come and you see
the the sad part you know angrily got to
be I said it might just be beautiful and
it might bring a tear out he needs the
type of thing that happened in this gang
you know I me a lot of us a lot of us
don't get a dick to the money we get
addicted to the love and what's going on
in and you know I'm saying you want to
get a new chick because you want to feel
that love one more time you want to feel
that camaraderie with that chick again
man you know any it don't even got to be
about the money all the time it's just
the fact that you know what she'll do
for you you know I'm saying and it's
just it's just so tough to explain that
to the to these young cats man cuz they
don't they don't have that opportunity
don't mourn all they can have is a
female to tell them oh I would die for
you when we had chicks that actually
took that chance and she proved that
they would you know and and that's a
gone a forgone time but I was blessed
enough to be during that time and be
able to be able to feel that love and
that and that pushed me on and motivated
me to try to be the best I could be in
and try to involve into whatever I could
possibly become what college did you
look for in a girl where y'all top
dedication and once again the same
quality look for me I wanted to be
honest you know I mean I want to know
man you know regardless what happened
don't lie to me because a lot is gonna
make it to where I'm always gonna think
about you're lying and that's gonna draw
a distance between us you know even if
it's embarrassing or it may hurt you and
just tell the truth you know I'm saying
so
dedication honesty I mean you you you
prefer them definitely look nice but
yeah as most of us know it ain't in the
beauty is in the duty you
I'm saying so those are the main things
you want I mean I I make it visually
blinded by her appearance if her if her
conduct is a hundred percent I don't
care how she looked you know I'm saying
so you know that's gonna be the main
thing you want to get around he wanted
me to you want to see how she dedicates
she asking you questions you know what
I'll do if this happens what I'll do it
that she's really trying to figure out
what to do to make this work between you
and her you know I'm saying those are
the things you want you don't want just
the chick that her main motive to
something else and she just bare to try
to reach that motive you know you could
tell that and it's not gonna last long
so my main thing is I like the
dedication and the camaraderie you know
and honesty all right
tipsy thank you so much man thank you
that's a great talk it was okay Church
y'all
you